coming up next week in Brussels and many
plenary defense economic governance and
money money money
welcome to the agenda kicking things off
a bit of join us and 500 finish workers
the Eva globalization adjustment fund
has a piggy bank of some 500 million
euros if you get to Member States on
Tuesday at the budget committee will
vote in Finland application to receive
one point three six five million euros
for the 568 workers may identify the
electronics firm Broadcom 2015 was
declared the year of development but
what's the plan for the years ahead
a hearing is set to take place at the
Parliament to discuss that very thing
the EU channels a lot of money into
development with projects to help
communities all over the world care of
poverty but were the effects of climate
change taking root what more can be done
find out on Monday as a mini plenary
returns to Brussels the big discussion
the upcoming EU Council on defense the
big question that does there need to be
a rethink on the EU security and defence
policy in recent years member states
have tightened their national defense
budgets has that had an effect on the
ease collective ability MEP s will
debate on Wednesday how to solve
Europe's economic problems while it's an
issue that continues to divide opinion
the Economic and Monetary Affairs
Committee voted in favor of a resolution
to tweak the rules on economic
governance last Tuesday the author of
the report has said that the fact that
the Commission President jean-claude
Juncker rolled out investment plan it
shows that the current system isn't
working the resolution will go to a vote
at the plenary on Wednesday well one way
to get the economy back on track is by
creating a better environment for
businesses and that's what's on the way
as a fairer tax system for corporations
is on the cards representatives of the
Commission at the plenary session with a
word on the action plan and as all we
have this agenda take care and enjoy the
week